jobin's idea is we're going to keep
spending money up the wazoo and somehow
this is going to check inflation
these disruptions are temporary you
can't flip the global economic
light back on and not expect this to
happen
joe biden continues to wish away
inflation a lot of people including
janet yellen who are saying that
inflation is going to maintain for
several more months
at this point now as i've been saying
there are two forces that are that are
at work in the american economy one is
joe biden blowing dollars into the
american economy artificially lowering
the labor rate because people are
literally staying out of work because
they're being paid to stay home
and artificially inflating the price of
goods because we have a bunch of
bottlenecks
in all the distribution systems and
that's being exacerbated by money
chasing fewer goods which leads to price
inflation
all of this rooted in the notion that
somehow equity is achieved if you just
helicopter cash to people which has
never been the case anywhere in history
okay so joe biden is saying that that's
not raising inflation no no
you're crazy you might be looking at
that inflation rate and saying yourself
wait a second
aren't i i mean the prices are up aren't
they he says no no nobody
no one is suggesting unchecked inflation
is on the way
says our our derelict president
there's nobody suggesting there's
unchecked inflation on the way
no serious economist that's totally
different i mean look
the stock market is higher than it has
been in all of history even went
down this month even down this month now
i don't look at the stock market as a
means by which to judge the economy like
my
my uh predecessor did but he'd be very
he'd be talking
every day the last five months about how
the stock market's so high
higher than any time in history still
higher than any time in history
so that's not how i judge whether or not
we have economic growth
oh well you know he's going to judge you
by the stock market weird he wasn't
doing that when trump was president but
but that's always the way that this
works
then joe biden follows up that doozy by
suggesting that the inflation is
temporary and in fact you know how
you're going to solve inflation
we're going to solve inflation by
artificially boosting the growth
okay this is like the dumbest thing
economically speaking
that i've heard recently his theory is
that inflation is
going up so if you blow more money into
the economy that will jog the spending
which will eventually bring the
inflation down which is a hell of a take
that's a that's a hot take bull move
there cotton
our experts believe and the data shows
that most of the price increases we've
seen
are were expected and expected to be
temporary
reality is you can't flip the global
economic light
back on and not expect this to happen
as demand returns there's going to be
global supply chain challenges
we've seen that in semiconductors which
are used in automobiles
that global shortage has slowed vehicle
production
creating a temporary spike in car prices
that's a real challenge my
administration's doing everything we can
to address it
but again these disruptions are
temporary
okay you know what would be temporary is
if you didn't artificially boost the
money supply it would have been
temporary there was going to be a
natural economic recovery go back listen
to my podcast
last year i said when this was over
there would be a major economic boom
because the economy was doing great
and then it was put into an artificial
coma and now the artificial coma is
ending
maybe if the left will allow it to end
and people are going to go out and
they're going to spend again in fact
people ended last year with more net
savings than they had the year before
because the government had already put
so much money in their pocket joe
biden's idea is we're going to keep
spending money
up the wazoo and somehow this is going
to check inflation
interesting idea now the reality is that
when you remove this much money from the
private economy and when everybody
understands
that the the regulatory schemes that
biden is pursuing will hurt business
and that taxation is eventually going to
be around the corner when everybody
realizes that
the next move is that the economy starts
to stagnate
is what we call secular stagnation we've
seen it in japan japan
was the country that was going to take
over the world in the 1980s if you go
back and watch die hard
in like 1989 1990. you go back and watch
die hard
what you'll see is that the nakatomi
plaza right the whole metaphor
is supposed to be that japan was a great
threat to the united states they were
going to be taking over all of our
businesses taking over the world
economically speaking
and then they went into fully uh full on
like a decade of secular stagnation
because they'd inflated their currency
and it turns out that the demand was not
keeping up with anything remotely
approaching
the supply so what you ended up with was
was this sort of very slow rate of
growth
that destroyed the japanese growth and
boom
of the 1980s by the 1990s japan
basically burned out
you could see exactly the same thing
here and joe biden's own administration
is foreseeing this by the way
you wonder why they're trying to
distract with things like all
republicans are jim crow donald trump
january
the reason they're doing that is because
they all know that within two years
secular stagnation is likely to set in
and we're gonna be growing not at seven
percent
in an artificially boosted rebound from
a pandemic from an artificial coma
what's most likely is that in a couple
of years we're gonna be growing at like
1.8 percent
two percent in fact if you look at joe
biden's own 10-year proposed budget
that budget suggests that in just a
couple of years we're going to spend the
rest of the decade growing at
exorbitantly low levels
very very low levels the reason the
countries
grow at very low levels is because they
have put too many burdens
on the actual entrepreneurs and job
creators in their economy
it's because they've made it difficult
to do business in their economy joe
biden doesn't care about that because he
understands that the way that politics
works
is that the bigger the things you get
done are the less it matters whether
they actually succeed
one of the great annoyances that i have
with regard to historians is the way
that they treat for example the 1920s
which were a boom time in the united
states has some sort of horrible time
for american governance and the 1930s
which was the great depression as a
wonderful time for american governance
why because political history buffs are
people who are interested in action
they're interested in action and if a
president does big things
it doesn't matter that they're a
complete failure lbj very important
president complete failure
fdr very very important president
absolute failure
on virtually every level except for the
handling of world war ii
hey fdr's handling of the great
depression was egregiously bad
and there's a great hilarity to the fact
that presidential historians rate
herbert hoover super low but fdr super
high when fdr
literally did what herbert hoover did
except a little more
in fact everybody in the fdr
administration acknowledged that they
were doing what herbert hoover did
the reason that herbert hoover is
treated with disdain and fdr with glory
is because
fdr of course was a democrat and herbert
hoover was a republican but the best
president of the 20th century
at least up until ronald reagan the best
presidents of the 20th century
were the presidents of the early 20s
william harding
calvin coolidge and these are the people
who are disdained how do i know that
they were good presidents
look at the economic growth rates from
1920 to 1929.
massive and if you say well look at the
great depression that was 1920 yes
that's true because the reaction to the
great depression was not
to sit there and wait for it to peter
out instead
the reaction to the stock market crash
of october 1929 was to get government
involved in
extremely invasive ways in american life
but this again goes to why joe biden is
doing any of this
because if you're joe biden the
incentives for politicians and this is
true for members of congress it's true
for senators
it's true for president the incentives
the incentive structure is to get
big things done and this is the problem
with centralizing this much power in the
hands of government
whether you're talking about the public
health establishment or the incentive is
to control
centralize and quote unquote get things
done or whether you're talking about in
the financial sphere
where the incentive is to control and
centralize and quote-unquote get things
done
the first rule of politics and public
health should be very simple
do no harm but that's not the political
incentive
the political incentive is do something
you see this all the time when people
talk politics they say yeah i see a
problem why can't we just do something
just do something
we should be treating politics like a
doctor would treat a patient the first
rule is
don't kill the patient do no harm
and yet that is precisely the opposite
of our of our modern incentive structure
particularly in the media where people
who are the most activist
are considered the most thoughtful and
the and the greatest leaders
why andrew cuomo was a hero while
killing all the olds in his state
while ron desantis who basically
restricted his action to protecting the
elderly
was considered some sort of horrific
human rights violator by the left
we need to change our mindset with
regard to what government is designed to
do otherwise we are just going to get
endless government quote unquote action
that brings about precisely the opposite
of that which it intends to to
bring about i know what you're thinking
it's time to binge some more ben shapiro
videos well you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video